So today we turned to,
uh,
a mode of doing literary criticism,
which was extraordinarily widespread in
beginning in the late seventies and into
the 80s, uh, called the
new historicism. It was,
uh, it definable in ways that I'll,
that I'll turn to in a minute.
And, uh, as I say,
prevalent to a remarkable
degree everywhere. Uh,
it began probably at the University
of California at Berkeley, uh,
under the auspices and
part of Steven Greene Blat,
who's a brief essay you've read for today,
Greenblatt and others,
uh, founded a journal,
still one of the most important and
influential journals in the field of
literary study called Representation's.
Um,
always has been,
still is an Oregon for new
historicist thought. Uh,
it's the movement which began,
uh,
primarily preoccupied with
the early modern period,
so called renaissance. The new
historicism, uh, is in effect,
responsible for the replacement of the
term renaissance with the term, uh,
early modern, uh, and, uh, it's influence,
however quickly did extend
to other fields. Um,
some fields perhaps more than
others. It would be, I think,
probably worth a lecture that I'm not
going to give to explain why certain
fields somehow or another,
seem to lend themselves more readily to
new historicist approaches than others.
I think it's fair to say that in
addition to the early modern period,
the three fields that have been most
influenced by the newest eracism CISM or
the 18th Century British Romanticism,
uh,
and Americanists Studies,
uh, from the, uh,
late colonial through the
Republican period, uh,
the age, the emergence of print culture,
the emergence of the public sphere, uh,
as a medium of influence.
And the distribution of knowledge,
uh,
in the United States has
been a very fruitful,
he studied from new historicist points of
view. So those are the fields that are,
that are most directly influenced,
uh, by this approach. Uh,
when you read it went, when we
discussed the German McGann's essay,
you'll see how, uh, it influences,
uh, romantic studies. Uh,
now the newest Doris CISM, um, is, was,
and this probably accounts for its
remarkable popularity and influence,
uh, in the period roughly from the late
seventies through the early nineties,
the newest Doris and was a
response to an increasing sense of
ethical failure and the isolation of the,
as it was allegedly practiced in
certain forms of literary study,
beginning with the new criticism
through the period of deconstruction,
uh,
the recondite a discourse
of Lacan and others.
In psycho analysis,
there was a feeling
widespread among scholars,
especially younger scholars
that somehow or another, uh,
especially in response
to pressing concerns,
a sort of post Vietnam concerns
with globalization concerns with the
distribution of power, uh, uh, and um, uh,
and global capital. Uh, all
of these concerns, um, uh,
inspired what one can only call a
guilt complex in a academic literary
scholarship and led to
a return to history. Uh,
it was felt that,
um,
that a kind of ethical tipping
point had been arrived at, uh,
and that the, uh, modes of analysis
that had been flourishing, um,
needed to be superseded by modes of
analysis in which a history and the
political implications of what one
was doing, uh, became prominent.
And Central. Uh, I have to say that, uh,
in debates of this kind,
there's always a considerable amount
of hot air perhaps on both sides.
Uh,
in many ways it's not the case that the
so-called isolated approaches really
were isolated. A deconstruction
in its second generation, uh,
wrote perpetually about history,
uh, and undertook to Orient,
uh, the techniques of deconstruction
to an understanding of history. Uh,
just to give one example and the
new historicism on the other hand,
um,
events,
a preoccupation with issues of
form and textual integrity that,
uh,
certainly followed from the disciplines,
the approaches that preceded them.
And also to a large degree.
And this is of course true of a good
many other approaches that we're about to
investigate approaches based
in questions of identity.
Also to a large degree appropriated
the language of the generation of the
deconstructionists.
And to a certain extent,
certain underlying was died is having
to do with the binder of binary
relationship between self and
other binary relationships among,
uh, uh, social entities, uh,
as opposed to linguistic entities,
but still, as I say, inheriting, uh,
the essentially inheriting the structure
of thought of preceding approaches.
So as I say,
it was in an atmosphere,
in a polemical atmosphere
and at a moment of uh,
widespread self doubt in,
uh,
the academic literary profession that
the new historicism came into its own a
response,
as I say,
to the isolation of the text by certain
techniques and approaches to it.
Now,
very quickly,
the method of new historical analysis,
uh,
fell into a pattern,
a very engaging one,
one that's wonderfully exemplified by
the brief introduction of Greenblatt that
is, uh, that, that,
that I've asked you to read a pattern
of beginning with an anecdote,
uh, often, uh, rather far afield,
at least apparently rather far afield
from the literary issues that are
eventually turned to, uh, in
the argument of a given essay.
A Dusty Miller was walking down the road,
uh,
thinking about nothing in particular
when he encountered a bailiff, you know,
uh, and then certain legal issues
arise. Uh, and uh, somehow or another,
the next thing you know, we're
talking about king lear. Uh, this, uh,
rather marvelous,
um,
oblique way into a literary topics was um,
going to,
uh,
the brilliance in handling it
of Greenblatt in particular
and Louie Mantrose and
some of his colleagues.
This, uh, this technique, um,
became a kind of a hallmark
of the new historicism in
the long run. Of course. Uh,
it was easy enough,
uh,
to parody it and it has been
subjected to parody, uh,
and in a certain sense has,
uh,
been modified and chastened by
the prevalence of parity. Uh,
but nevertheless, um, I think, um,
shows you something about the way new,
newer historicist thinking works.
It is the newest or us isn't,
is interested following food co and
Fuko is the primary interest on the new
historicism. I won't say as much, uh,
about this today as I might feel obliged
to say if I weren't soon be going to
return to Fukiko. And the
context of Gender Studies, uh,
when we take up Fuko and
Judith Butler together.
But I will say briefly
that food co's writing,
especially his later writing,
is about the pervasiveness,
the circulation through social
orders of what he calls power.
Now, power is not just, or
in many cases in Foodco,
not even primarily the
power of vested authorities,
the power of violence,
uh,
the power of tyranny from above power in
Fuko though it can be those things and
frequently is,
is much more pervasively.
And also insidiously the way in which
knowledge circulates in a culture.
That is to say the way in which
what we think, what we think,
that it is appropriate to think,
uh,
acceptable thinking is distributed by
largely unseen forces in a social network
or social system. Power. In other words,
in food co is in a certain sense,
knowledge, or to put it another way,
it is the explanation of how certain
forms of knowledge come to exist.
Knowledge, by the way, not necessarily
have something that's true.
Certain forms of knowledge come
to exist in certain places.
So all of this is central to the work
of Fuko and is carried over by the new
historicist. Hence the interest
for them of the anecdote.
Start as far a field as you can imagine,
ugly start from what you will
finally be talking about,
which is probably some
textual or thematic issue in,
in Shakespeare or in the Elizabethan
mask or whatever the case may be.
Start as far afield as you possibly can
from that precisely in order to show the
pervasiveness of a
certain kind of thinking,
the pervasiveness of a certain social
constraint or limitation on freedom.
If you can show how pervasive it is,
you reinforce and justify
the food called in idea.
That power is, as I've said, uh, uh,
and insidious and ubiquitous
mode of circulating knowledge.
So all of this is implicit,
sometimes explicit in new historicist
approaches to what they do,
what they do.
So as I said,
Fuko is the crucial antecedent.
Uh,
and of course,
when it's a question of who co
literature as we want to conceive of it,
perhaps generically or as a particular
kind of utterance as opposed to other
kinds,
does tend to collapse back into the
broader or more a general notion of
discourse. Uh, because it's discourse,
it's by means of discourse that
power circulates knowledge.
Uh, once again, you know,
despite the fact that historicism
wants to return us to the real world,
it nevertheless acknowledges that
that return is language bound.
It is by means of language
that the real world, uh, uh,
shapes itself.
That's why for the new historicist and
we will buy this means I'll turn it in a
moment to the marvelous anecdote with
which Greenblatt begins the brief essay
that I've asked you to read.
That's why the new historicist lays such,
such intense emphasis on the idea that
the relationship between discourse call
it literature if you like,
you might as well. Uh,
the relationship between history
and discourse is reciprocal.
Yes.
History conditions,
what literature can say in a given epoch.
History is an important
way of understanding. Uh,
the valence see of certain
kinds of utterance at certain
kinds. In other words,
history is as it's traditionally
thought to be by the old historicism,
and I'll get to that in a minute.
History has a background
to discourse or literature,
but by the same token,
there is an agency that has to say a
capacity to circulate power in discourse.
In turn,
call it literature.
I am Richard the second.
No you not,
that says Queen Elizabeth when at the
time of the threatened Essex uprising,
she gets wind of the fact that Richard
the second is being performed as she
believes in the public streets and
in private houses. In other words,
wherever there is sedition,
wherever there are people who want to
overthrow her and replace her with the
Earl of Essex,
the pretender to the throne,
Richard the second is
being performed well. Now,
this is terrifying to Queen Elizabeth
because she knows she's a supporter of the
theater.
She knows that Richard,
the second is about a
king who has many virtues,
but a certain weakness,
political weakness,
and also weakness of temperament, guide
of weakness that makes him, you know,
sit upon the ground and tell sad tales
about the death of kings. You know,
that kind of weakness who is then user
served by Bolingbroke who became Henry
the fourth. Ah, introducing
a whole new, uh,
dynasty. Uh, and, and, and,
and, and, and, and focus of,
of the royal family in England.
Queen this Queen Elizabeth says they're
staging this plot because they're trying
to compare me with Richard the second
and preparation for deposing me and who
knows what else they might do to me.
So everything you know,
is this, this is a matter
of great concern. In other
words, literature. I mean,
Fredric Jameson says,
history hurts,
literature hurts to literature,
and other words has a discursive agency
that affects history every bit as much
as history affects literature,
literature out there,
theater, especially if, if it escapes
the confines of the playhouse.
Because as Greenblatt argues,
the playhouse has a
certain mediatory effect,
which diffuses the
possibilities of sedition. Uh,
w one views,
uh,
literary representation in the
playhouse with a certain objectivity,
perhaps that is,
that is absent altogether when interested
parties take up the same text and
stage it precisely for the purpose
of fomenting rebellion. Um,
and so, uh, literature,
especially when Kate went,
when escaped from its
conventional confines, uh,
becomes a very,
very dangerous or positive influence
depending on your point of view on the
course of history.
So the relationship between history
and discourse is reciprocal.
Now in this,
uh,
Greenblatt wants to argue very v w with
a tremendous amount of stress and I
think effectiveness in this,
uh,
the new historicism differs from the
old historicism page 1443 and the right
hand column,
John Dover Wilson,
a traditional Shakespeare scholar,
and a very important one
is the spokesperson in
Greenblatt's scenario for the
old historicism.
And so the view I'm about to quote
is that of Don John Dover Wilson,
a kind of consensus about the relationship
between literature and history.
Modern historical scholarship,
meaning old historicism has assured
Elizabeth that she had this as the right
hand column,
but two thirds of the way down has
assured Elizabeth that she had nothing to
worry about. Richard. The
second is not at all subversive,
but rather a him to tutor ordered the
play far from encouraging thoughts of
rebellion,
regards the deposition of the legitimate
king as a sac religious act that drags
the country down into an abyss of
chaos that Shakespeare and his audience
regarded Bolingbroke as a usurper declares
John Dover Wilson is incontestable
but in 1601 neither Queen
Elizabeth nor the Earl of Essex.
We're so sure green black wins.
I mean, it's a wonderful example.
It's the genius of Greene Blat to
choose examples that are so telling.
And so in controvertible we know Queen
Elizabeth was scared on this occasion.
Um,
and it's at,
which makes it quite simply the case
that John Dover Wilson was wrong.
Suppose that retroed the second
was no threat to her. It's not the,
it's not a all the point that the,
a broad ideological view of Richard.
The second was any different from what
Wilson said. It was perfectly true.
Bolingbroke was considered a usurper.
It was considered tragic that
Richard the second was deposed.
But that doesn't mean that the text
can't be taken over commandeered and made
subversive.
Wilson doesn't acknowledge this because
his view of the relationship between
history and literature is all in
the history influences literature,
not that the influence can be reciprocal.
You see,
that's how it is that the new historicism
wants to define itself over and
against the old historicism.
If there is a political or
ideological consensus about,
uh,
legitimacy of monarchy,
divine right of kings,
legitimacy of success and under the
sanction of the Church of England and all
the rest of it,
all of which is anachronistic.
When you were thinking
about these history plays,
if there is this broad consensus,
that's it.
That's what the play means
according to the old historicism.
Even though play Ley,
you can take the plot of the play
and completely invert those values,
which is what the Essex faction
does and staging it, ah,
in those places where Queen Elizabeth
success suspects that it's being staged.
Okay.
Now another way in which the old
historicism and the new historicism differ
correctly. I think according to Greene
Blat is that in the old historicism?
There is no question.
I'm looking at page 1444 of the right
hand column about a third of the way down
and the oldest Doris says,
there's no question of the the real,
the role of the historians
own subjectivity.
It is not thought says Greenblatt
to be the product of the historians
interpretation history is just what is
will on views it objectively and that's
that.
Now notice here that we're back with
God Umer remember that this was God
hammers, accusation of
historicism. It's belief,
the belief of historicism,
what Greenblatt calls the old historicism,
that we can bracket out
our own historical horizon,
that we can eliminate all of our own
historical prejudices in order to
understand the past
objectively in and for itself.
This is not the case.
Said God. Remember God,
Omer said that interpretation
must necessarily involve
the merger of horizons,
the horizon of the other
and my own horizon.
As an interpreter,
I cannot bracket out my own subjectivity.
Okay.
If that's the case,
then God them or anticipates Greenblatt
and saying that the naive putty of the
old historicism is it's supposition that
it has no vested interest in what it's
talking about.
That is to say it's a position that he,
that it wants history to a cord
in one way or another with its own
preconceptions but isn't aware
of it. The anecdote, again,
a wonderfully placed in the polemical
argument that after all John Dover Wilson
delivered himself of these opinions about
Richard the second before a group of
scholars in Germany in 1939 is after all
rather interesting Hitler is about to
be the Bolingbroke of Germany.
John Dover Wilson Watson,
his audience to say, Hey, wait a minute.
You know, stick with vested authority.
You know, you have a weak
democracy, but it is a democracy.
Don't let it get away from
you. You know, uh, and,
and so he is speaking, um, you know,
the horse already having escaped from
the barn in this reassuring way about
German politics as a means of sort of
reinforcing his own view of the politics
of Elizabethan England.
But this greenglass opposes it.
Something about which he has very little
self consciousness that is to say he
just,
he,
he his own interest as of course
it should be on this occasion,
is in the preservation
of vested authority, uh,
and his own interests then folds back
into his understanding of Elizabethan
ideology in such a way that it can
conform to that interest he has.
In other words, in short, as we say today,
a hidden agenda and is
very little aware of it,
unlike the new historicist
who following God.
Hammer in this respect is fully cognizant
of the subjective investment that,
uh, leads to a choice of
interest in materials,
a way of thinking about those materials
and a means of bringing them to life for
us today and into focus.
In other words,
it's okay for a Greenblatt as it was for
God gossamer much to the horror of Ed
Hirsch to find the significance of a
text as opposed to the meaning of a text.
The significance of the text is that it
has a certain kinds of power invested in
it. Those kinds of power are
still of interest to us today,
still have relevance to what's
going on in our own world.
All of this is taken up openly,
uh,
as a matter of self consciousness
by the new historicist, uh,
in ways that according to
Greenblatt and his colleagues, uh,
uh, we're not available,
uh, consciously, uh,
in the older historicism
now the world as the news,
as the new historicism sees it.
And after I've said this,
I'll turn to McGahn the world as the
new historicism sees it is essentially a
dynamic interplay of power,
networks of power and subversion.
That is to say modes of
challenging those networks. Uh,
even within,
uh,
the authoritative texts that
generate positions of power,
the Elizabethan mask for
example, uh, which stages,
uh,
the relation of court to Cordier
to a visitor to hang her on,
uh, in wonderfully orchestrated ways, um,
is a means because it's kind
of poly vocal is a means of,
of containing within its structure,
elements of subversion according to the
argument that's made about these things.
The same with court ritual itself.
The same with the, uh, the,
uh, happenstance that takes place
once a year in early modern England,
uh, in which the Lord of Misrule, uh, is,
is d is so denominated,
uh,
and ordinary authority is
turned on its ear for one day,
Queen for a day, uh, as it were,
is something that is available
to any citizen once a year. Um,
and these are all ways of diffusing what
they in fact bring into visibility and
consciousness,
namely the existence,
perhaps the inevitable existence of
subversion with respect to structures and
circulatory systems of power.
And it's this relationship between power
and subversion that the newest Doris is
and especially in taking up issues of the
early modern period tends to focus and
to specialize in.
Now,
Jerome McGann is,
it's not wholly clear that Jerome again
has ever really thought of himself as a
new historicist.
He has been so designated by others,
but I think there is one rather
important difference in emphasis,
at least between what he's doing and what
a green bond and his colleagues do in
the early modern period.
Um,
mum again doesn't really so much
stress the reciprocity of history and
discourse. He is interested
in the presence of history,
the presence of immediate social and also
personal circumstances in the history
of a text.
His primary concern is with,
at least in this essay is
with textual scholarship.
He himself is the,
uh,
editor of the new standard works of Byron.
He has also done a standard
works of Swinburne, uh,
and he has been,
uh,
a vocal and colorful spokesperson of
a certain point of view within the
recondite debates of textual scholarship,
whether textual scholarship ought to be
or to produce a text that's an amalgam
of a variety of available
manuscripts and credit tax,
whether the texts that produces ought
to be the last and best thoughts of the
author. That's the position that again,
seems to be taking, uh, in this essay.
Whether the text on the
contrary ought to be, you know,
the first burst of
inspiration of the author. Uh,
all the people who prefer the earliest
versions of Wordsworth prelude for
example, uh, would favor that
point of who, um, in other words,
McGahn is making a contribution here
at least to the debates surrounding,
uh, editing, uh,
and the production of
authoritative scholarly texts.
It's in that context,
uh,
that the remarks he's making
about Keats have to be understood.
I think the primary influence on McGahn
is not so much Fuko then with this sense
of the sort of circulation of power
back and forth between history and
literature and literary discourse as
Bactine whom he quotes a on pages 18 and
19, or who's influenced he
sites I should say, rather, uh,
in a way that I think does pervade,
uh, what you encounter in reading.
Uh, what he then goes on
to say bottom of page 18,
what follows it says McGahn is a summary,
an extrapolation of certain key ideas
set forth by the so called buck teen
school of criticism,
a small group of Marxists,
good x from the Soviet Union who made an
early attack upon formalist approaches
to poetry just as he began.
And as the new historicist are themselves
in their turn doing the Bach teens
schools,
socio historical method approaches
all language utterances,
including poems as phenomena marked
with their concrete origins and history.
That is to say phenomena voiced by the
material circumstances that produced them
phenomenon.
In other words,
in which the voice of the sort of
romantic solitary is not really,
uh,
that voice at all.
But it's rather the poly Glassell
infusion of a variety of perspectives,
including ideological
perspectives shaping, uh,
that particular utterance.
And also in the,
in the case of the textual scholar,
uh,
shaping which have a variety
of manuscripts will be
chosen for publication and
for central attention in the tradition
of the reception of a given text.
So all of this, uh, uh, McGahn, uh,
takes to be derived from buck teen,
uh,
rather than from Foodco.
So I do think that's a significant
difference between our two authors.
Now I'm against most,
uh,
important contribution to the return to
history of the seventies and eighties is
a book,
a short book called the romantic ideology.
And this book, well, what it
is, is an attack on romanticism.
At least it's an attack on certain widely
understood and received ideas about
romanticism, ideas with which,
by the way, I don't agree,
but this course isn't about me.
Uh,
the romantic ideology is
an amalgam of two titles,
one of them as the important early
critique of Romanticism by the German poet
and sometime romantic Heinrich
hyena called d romanticist Shula,
the romantic school,
uh,
in which the subjectivity,
even solipsism isolation
from social concern, uh,
and from, uh, and, and,
and from unfolding historical processes
of the romantic poets is emphasized and
criticized. And in addition
to that, that's the word.
That's where the word romantic comes from
in the title of the Romantic ideology.
And the other title that it amalgamates
is Marxists book the German ideology,
which is about many things,
but as in particular about room
lumpenproletariat intellectuals who think,
ah, with Hagle still following Hagle
despite the believing themselves to be
progressive who think with Hagle that
thought produces material circumstances
rather than the other way around.
In other words,
people in short who are idealists
and therefore under this indictment,
also romantic. And so
again, it's title as I say,
cleverly amalgamates these two other
titles and sets the agenda for this short
book,
which is an attack not just on romanticism
but what but on what he believes to
be our continued tendency
still to be in romanticism,
still to be romantic.
And there his particular object of
attack is the so called Yale School,
um,
who are still under attack in the
Essa that you've read for today.
Uh,
Paul Demonn and Geoffrey Hartman's a
well known essay on Keats's to autumn or
singled out for a particular,
uh, scorn and does praise. Um,
and so, and, and, and all sort
of on the grounds that, um,
yes, it's all very well to
read romanticism to conduct,
come to understand it,
even to be fascinated by it. But we
can't be romantic. In other words,
our reading of Romanticism,
if we are to be social animals,
politically engaged, invested, uh,
in the world as a social community,
uh,
our reading of Romanticism
must necessarily be an
auntie romantic critique.
This is a, as I say, still
essentially the position taken up,
taken up by [inaudible]. I
mean, I'm sorry by him again.
All right.
So I've,
I've explained the ways in which he
defers from Greenblatt and leaning more
toward Bach teen than toward
Fuko. Um, I've explained that, uh,
McGahn is engaged primarily and talking
about issues of textual scholarship in
this particular essay that he defends
Keats's last deliberate choices that he
believes the so called
indicator text of 18,
20 of Lavelle.
Don saw marriage song.
Mercy is Keats's last deliberate choice,
uh,
as opposed to the 1848
text, uh, published, uh,
by a monk to mills, uh,
in the addition of Keats,
his poems that he brought
out at that time. Now
I think that in that,
in the time I,
I want to sort of linger over McGann,
I do want to say a few things
about what he says about Keats.
I want to, I want to, to,
to emphasize that his
general pronouncements about
the historicity of texts,
about the permeation of texts by the
circumstances of their production,
uh, their conditioning by
ideological factors, uh,
is unimpeachable.
Uh,
it seems to me that this is a necessary
approach at least to have in mind,
if not perhaps necessarily to
emphasize in one's own work of literary
scholarship. Uh, the idea that
a text just falls from a tree,
um, if anybody ever had
that idea, by the way,
is plainly not a tenable
one. Um, and the, uh,
and the opposite idea that
the tax that it texts is a,
is emerges from a complex matrix of
social and historical circumstances is,
uh, is certainly a good one.
So if one's to criticize,
but again, it's not a question of
criticizing his basic pronouncements.
It seems to me, um, nothing. I think
it'd be said really against them.
The trouble is that in the case of McGann,
who's a,
who's a terrific prominent
romantic scholar, uh,
with whom one I suppose hesitates to
disagree. And in the case of McGann,
everything he says about the texts
that he isolates for attention.
And this essay is simply consistently
wrong. I mean, it is, I mean,
it,
it's almost as if pi compulsion that he
says things that are wrong about these
texts.
And I just,
and the reason I asked you in my email
last night to take a look at them if you
got a chance is so that,
um,
so that these few remarks that I
make now might have some substance.
Uh, take for example, La
Beldam. So I'm artsy, uh,
in the first place.
Who says,
we only read the 1848 text us scholarly
edition and his main object of attack is
Jacksonville injures
scholarly edition of Kate's.
A scholarly edition gives you
basically a variorum apparatus.
Yeah. Maybe it gives you a
particular text in bold print,
but it gives you the variant text in
smaller print and the in a footnote it,
you know, it, it doesn't
withhold the variant texts
from him. He says, it says, no,
look, there's this to, you know, take
your choice. Really the, the, the,
the atmosphere of a variorum scholarly
edition is an atmosphere of take your
choice,
not a kind of tyrannical,
a imposition on the public of a
particular version of the text.
Everybody knows the 1820 indicator texts.
What can nail the wretched white is at
least as familiar to me as a romanticist,
as what can l the United arms,
the way in which the 1848 tax begins.
And frankly,
how many raw mat people
who aren't romanticist know
anything about either text.
I mean, what are we talking
about here for the wrong?
The romanticist know what going on.
They're not in any way hornswoggled by
this historical conspiracy against the
1820 indicator taxed. And people who
aren't romances don't care. That's what,
that's what it comes down to.
But I mean,
if it's not enough simply to say that,
you know, turning to the question,
which text is better? Well, it's
hard to say which text is better.
Mcgann's argument is that the 1820 is
better because it's a poem about a guy and
a girl who sort of meat and
the next thing you know,
they're having sex and that doesn't
turn out so well. In other words,
it's about the real world. These
things happen. Uh, it's not a romance,
whereas the,
what can LD wretched night,
the 1848 version and all
of its, uh, other variants,
the kisses for and so on.
Uh, the 1848 version, um,
is, uh, kind of unselfconscious
in McGann's view,
romance, subscribing to certain
medieval ideas about women, uh,
simultaneously putting them on a
pedestal that pedestal and, and,
and fearing at the same time,
uh,
that they're invested with a
kind of black magic which, which,
which destroys the souls and s and
dissipates the SAP of deserving young
gentlemen. Um, all of this, you know,
is ideologically programmed according
to him again in the 1848 version.
Why? Because Charles Brown
behave despicably toward women.
He didn't like fanny Brawne. Uh,
and because Monkton millions,
the actual editor of the 1848 edition
loved pornography and was a big collector
of erotica.
Uh,
so that's why the 1848 text with it's,
uh,
w w w w with,
it's a fear of and denigration of
women in contrast to the 1820 texts is
superior. Well, two things. First of all,
who's to say the 1848 texts
wasn't Keats's last thoughts.
In other words,
yes,
he was already ill when the indicator
taxed was published in 1820.
It is pretty close to the
end of his ability to think
clearly about his own work
and to worry very much about the
forms in which it was published.
But at the same time,
we don't know when Brown
received his version of the text.
We can't suppose as Mcgann,
more than half applies that Brown
just sort of sat down and rewrote it.
And then nobody,
nobody has ever really said that.
And if he didn't rewrite it, then Keith's
must've given it to him in that form.
Who's to say that wasn't
his last and best thoughts.
Who's to say Kate's didn't
really want to write a poem?
This kind of after all the title taken
from Amy and evil ballad by eyelash
shock,
Jay [inaudible] mercy,
it bears out the, the, the, the,
the what can l the United arms version.
It's about a Morgan La fe type. It's
about, I mean, for better or worse,
whatever we think of that ideologically
it is about if the title is right,
uh, the kind of woman who is, who is, uh,
evoked in the 1848 version as opposed to
the kind of woman who is evoked in the
1820 versions. So the 1848 is simply
more consistent with the title.
That's one point to be made,
but the additional point to be made
is that taking advantage of the new
historicist acknowledgement
that one's own subjectivity,
one's own historical
horizon is properly in play.
In thinking about these things again,
uh,
is then able to infuse Keats's texts and
therefore Keats his intentions with a
pleasing political correctness.
That is to say Keith's cat possibly
have thought in that demeaning way about
women by the way, everything,
I mean I like kids,
but everything in his letters suggest
that he did a key Keats Keats can't
possibly have thought in that
demeaning way about women.
Therefore,
the 1820 text is the text that
he intended and preferred.
Okay.
That of course,
makes Keats more consistent with our
own standards and our own view of the
relations between the sexes. But does
it make Keats, does it? In other words,
make sense?
Uh,
visa vi the Kate's whom we know and
despite his weaknesses and shortcomings
love, uh, and so there is a great
deal, in other words, to be sad,
uh,
over against McGann's assertions
about this textual issue.
Not necessarily in defense of the 1848,
but agnostically with respect
to the two of them saying, yeah,
we better have both of them were
better put them side by side,
we'd better read them together.
But if by some theology,
the 1820,
where somehow subsequently
preferred to the 1848,
that would be every bit as much,
uh,
of an historical misfortune
as the preference insofar
as it has actually existed
of the 1848 for the 1820 [inaudible].
Uh,
and so I think that's the
perspective one wants to take. Now,
I was going to talk about, um, to autumn,
I'll only say about his reading of,
to autumn that McGann who, who doesn't
seem to like the poem very much. I mean,
he likes La Belden Song mercy. So
it makes it politically correct. Uh,
he doesn't like to autumn because he
thinks that autumn was published in
collusion with Keats's conservative
friends and the poems of 1820, uh,
which burglarized everything he had to
say of a progressive political nature.
And he thinks that to autumn
is a big sellout. In other
words, that eight, yes, 18,
19 happened to be a year of good harvest.
And so Kate's turns that year of good
harvest into something permanent,
into a kind of cloud cuckoo land,
uh, in which, you know, the,
the fruit falls into your basket and the
fish jump into your net and everything
is just perfect. Well, do you
think the poem is really like that?
You've read the third stanza which began
totally ignores apart from where the
songs is spring. I, where
are they in there was he, he,
he gives you the opening but it doesn't
give you any sense of the rest of the
stands it for,
because for him to autumn is all
about the first stanza for him.
Kate seems to identify with the bees
who think warm days will never cease for
summer has or Brynn, their
clammy cells. Keats is like a B.
He's all into the sensuous. Well again,
just in terms of historical evidence,
this is outmoded by at least 18,
but by at least 18 months.
If we consult Keats's letters.
He was like that early in his career.
But he has had severe misgivings,
uh, about a PR point of view,
which is, uh, which is represented.
And what he said in an earlier letter
o for a life of sensations rather than
thoughts that's no longer Keats's
position when writing to autumn.
Kate's his position when riding off to
autumn is the position of a guy who has a
sore throat justices,
tubercular brother did,
who is increasingly afraid that he's going
to die soon and is trying to confront
mortality in writing.
What is in fact a,
and I say in fact advisedly,
the most perfect lyric ever
written in the English language,
which is Ma and which is most certainly
not a celebration of, you know,
uh,
sort of wandering around like an aimless
be thinking that the autumn is perfect,
but that autumn is always perfect. Uh,
and that warm days will never cease. Uh,
and that everything is just lovely. And
the garden that is not that kind of poem.
Uh,
and it's really a travesty of it to
suppose that it is simply on the grounds
that it was published in the poems
1820 a as a kind of sell out to the
establishment, uh, under the advice
of Keats's conservative friends.
All right so much then, um, for
McGann's remarks on Keets, which has a,
which I want to say again,
you know,
in no way in Pune or undermine the
general validity of the claims that he's
making about, uh, taking historical
circumstances into account precisely.
We need to take them into account
and we need to get them right.
That's the challenge of course,
of working with historical circumstances.
You have to get it right. Uh,
and so, uh, with that said, uh,
let me turn quickly to a review of Tony,
uh,
from Bactine to the new
historicism. I'm a, uh,
glide over,
uh,
Tony according to Jameson because we
did that at the end of the last lecture.
So let me go back to Bactine.
Uh,
you can see the way in which in the
structure of Tony The tow truck, uh,
the first part of the poem is absolutely
saturated with the first person
singular. I do this, I do that.
I liked my job, I am stuck.
I then as you read along through the text,
you'll see that the I disappears
or if it's still appears,
it's in the middle of a line rather
than at the beginning of the line.
In other words, that the eye, the
subjectivity, the first person singular,
the sense of having a unique voice is
gradually subsumed by the sociality of the
story as it unfolds.
I am no longer I defined
as a romantic individual.
I am,
I rather defined as a friend.
That is to say as a person
who has relation with
otherness is what constitutes
his identity.
And in that mutuality of friendship,
the first person singular disappears.
What is spoken in tone of the tow
truck, in other words, in the long run,
is not the voice of
individual subjectivity,
but the voice of social togetherness,
uh,
the voice of otherness
according to your house.
Uh,
the important thing about Tony the tow
truck is that it is not the same story as
the little engine that could and other
words in each generation of reception.
Uh,
the aesthetic standards that prevail
at a given time are reconsidered,
uh, and rethought, reshuffled
a new historical horizon,
a new aesthetic horizon emerges,
uh,
and texts are constituted
in a different way,
much also as the Russian
formalists have said,
only with the sense in the house of the
historical imperative little engine that
could, is all about the, uh,
inversion of power between the little guy
and the big guy so that the little guy
helps the big guy. Uh, and
that is unequivocal, uh,
showing as in Isaiah in
the Bible that the, uh, uh,
the valleys have been raised and the
mountains have been made low. Uh,
that's not the way Tony, the tow truck
works. The little guy himself needs help.
He needs the help of another little guy.
There is a reciprocity,
not dialectically between little and big,
but a mutual reinforcement
of little by little. Uh,
and that is the,
uh,
change in aesthetic horizon that one can
witness between the little engine that
could and Tony,
the tow truck and van,
you mean the important thing as I think
we've said is the idea that the narrator
is the apparatus.
The humanization of the natural world of,
I'm sorry,
the humanization of a mechanized world
through our identification with it is
what takes place in Tony the tow truck.
In other words, all these cars and trucks,
all these smiling and frowning houses,
uh,
of course have as their common
denominator there non humanity,
but the anthropomorphization of the
cars and trucks and have the houses
constitutes then as the human,
they are precisely the human.
We see things.
In other words,
from the point of view of the apparatus
we see just as the film goer sees things
from the point of view of the camera.
So we see Tony the tow truck from the
point of view of the tow truck, right?
And so it's all liquid and,
and what happens just as the camera
eye point of view leaves the,
that which is seen as Benyamin
puts it equipment free.
So oddly enough,
if we see things from the
standpoint of equipment,
what we look at is the moral of the story.
In other words,
the humanity of the story.
What we see, in other words,
surrounded by all of this equipment is
precisely the equipment free human aspect
of reality.
So to honor the tow truck works in a
way that is consistent with Benu means
theory of mechanical
reproduction for Adorno. However,
the acquiescence of this
very figure, the, the,
the apparatus of mechanical reproduction
of towing again and again and again,
the acquiescence of there's very figure
in the inequity of class relations
rejected as always by Nieto and speedy.
The acquiescence to this figure proves
that the apparatus which Benyamin is
there a tax to be independent of the
machinations of the culture industry,
that the apparatus in turn can be
suborned and commandeered by the culture
industry for its own purposes.
All right,
I will skip over Jameson,
the old historicism, which,
which read simply reconfirms [inaudible]
the old historicist reading of Tony
simply reconfirms a status quo in
which virtue as clear vice is clear,
uh, and both are uncontested,
uh, and nothing changes.
In other words, a status
quo, uh, which reflects, uh,
a stagnant, existent,
unchanging social dynamic,
the newest sources from a
lot of ways of doing this.
But let me just conclude by suggesting
that if literature influences history,
Donny,
the tow truck might well explain why
today we're promoting fuel efficient cars.
Uh,
why the attack on the gas
guzzler and the SUV or minivan?
I am too busy. Uh, why
the attack, what, what,
why the attack on these vehicles
is so prevalent in the story. Uh,
and why, uh, if we read today's headlines,
we need to get rid of the
Humvee if GM is to prosper, uh,
and we need to downsize and
streamline the available models.
The little guy,
Tony and bumpy reaffirm the need,
uh,
for a fuel efficient,
smaller vehicles. Uh,
and don't you can plainly see that Tony,
the tow truck is therefore a
discourse that produces history.
All of this,
uh,
according to the prescription of Tony
is actually happening. All right.
Thank you very much.
Um,
one thing that needs to be said about
Tony the tow truck is it has no women in
it. Ah, and that is the issue that
we'll be taking up on Thursday. Right.